des agents de sécurité en poste devant
un hôpital de lima la capitale
l'événement est important le terreau a
lancé ce mardi sa campagne nationale de
vaccination contre locaux vides 19 les
trois cent mille premières doses du
vaccin chinois sinopharm sont
administrées au personnel soignant
heureux d'être enfin vacciner
dieu merci le vaccin est arrivé et nous
allons continuer à prendre soin de nous
mêmes nous devons nous protéger je vais
continuer à prendre soin de moi comme si
je n'avais pas encore le vaccin
nous devons voir comment le vaccin n'a
fonctionné dans notre corps et cela va
encore prendre du temps beaucoup de
bonheur de joie et d'espoir que cette
catastrophe sanitaire prendra fin le
plus tôt possible surtout heureuse parce
que je suis enceinte et je pourrais
transmettre ces anticorps à mon bébé sur
un désert au port de lima des avions de
l'armée chargés de vaccins d'école en
direction des régions les plus touchées
par la seconde vague
dans la soirée c'est le président par
intérim francisco saga ch'ti qui se fait
administrer le vaccin en direct à la
télévision
nous sommes absolument sûrs que tous les
péruviens contribueront à la vaccination
du pérou
prenons tous le vaccin car c'est le
meilleur pour nous mêmes nos proches et
pour le pérou d'ici dimanche
le pérou devrait recevoir 700 mille
doses supplémentaires du vaccin de
sinopharm au total 38 millions de doses
du vaccin chinois ont été achetés par
lima mais aussi 20 millions du vaccin
germano américain pfizer bio ntech 14
millions du britannique oxford
astrazeneca et 13 millions à travers le
dispositif kovacs mis en place par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé